when i heard michelle's story well
i was really taken aback and i want you
to check it out here's michelle
hi my name is michelle gordon i am a
mother of
two a single mother of two now and i was
married for 13 years
this is now my second divorce and i
don't want to go back to the way i was
feeling the first time
the first divorce i was devastated but
um
i got through that and i really
you know don't want to ever feel that
way again so i'm just trying to learn
how to navigate in this new world that
we're living
in since i haven't been on a date or
anything in
13 years i was hoping to
find ways to pick myself up and get out
there again and maybe find someone who
wants to date or you know companionship
and someone who just wants to have fun
not necessarily looking for a husband
because i will never get married again i
would hopefully have
looking for any advice or tips or
anything that you know
you'd be willing to share
so michelle's story i definitely related
um and i wanted to surprise her with a
little
talk you know sort of like dating after
divorce discussion
and um i got a few of my friends
together to get
her ready for the date but the
conversation
is really what is the thing that kind of
surprised me the most take a look
hi it's so nice to meet you god no
i am so excited to meet you are you
kidding me we have
something in common which is i will
never
get married ever ever
most of the time i think the majority of
people although they get divorced
they're still
dealing with raising kids and all the
stuff that goes with it
all the time so it doesn't really feel
like a divorce it's
honestly you like you're saying adding
all those factors and you know i have
two children
and navigating through helping them and
you know i really want them to
understand there's nothing to do with
you
you know and he's a great man he's a
great person he's a great father
we just are not a good couple why do we
focus
so much on the fact that it didn't work
and the effect that that's going to have
on our children
rather than the fact that we were meant
to come together
to have these children i felt like i met
peter for a reason
i mean we had children and i got this
out of this relationship
and i mean i wouldn't trade that for the
world and
that's all i keep telling my children
there's nothing i regret
i have you i've never thought of it this
way myself
so i thank you for having this
conversation
so maybe we could get there together
yeah i would love that
how fun is it going to be
to date knowing that you will never be
this entangled with anyone again
i just not my relief almost like ah
cause i'm not trying to be that perfect
someone i'm not trying to be like oh
hope he loves me i hope he hope he falls
in love with me i hope i'm perfect i
hope he's the one cause i'm not looking
for the one
i know no i don't want the one i just
want one who wants to hang out have fun
companionship but i don't want to ever
be
the one right
and men love that pressure too by the
way yeah
exactly i think you have a date coming
up right
i do ronnie
ronnie um like i'm not gonna lie
your pictures together
yeah but i saw them apart i was like i
don't know
and then i saw them together and i was
like oh
i'm excited for this date i'd like to
introduce you to
um our dear friend of the show and just
a really
rad woman jamona hoffman who's like an
expert in this field
and i thought i would send lee harris
away he's who gets
me dressed every day well michelle i'm
[Music]
excited
you